you've got this 1996 Constitution which
is a multiracial Constitution where
whereby all citizens recall regardless
of their faith or ethnic background or
in principle equal citizens right but
South Africa's you know still remains
one of the most unequal societies on
earth in the context of of Muslims in in
Cape Town the transition to a post-assad
its society also intends entails a lot
of new freedoms you know there was a
process towards the gradual recognition
of Muslim marriages became in a lot of
respect easier for Muslims to express
their religious identity in in in public
and so forth on the report I'd of course
certain urban and suburban areas of Cape
Town were declared as whites only right
so you couldn't legally live there if if
you weren't classified by the system as
as white in the post apartheid context
this residential segregation still
remains but now it has more to do with
issues of class and social economic
marginalization so people who are not
white generally can't afford to move
into a circle white neighbors
neighborhoods from which some of them
were quite a substantial number where
were forcibly removed on reported when
these areas where declared white right
you know fears about Muslim immigration
often become completely overblown right
if you look at you know media and
political discourses there's not a
single day and there hasn't been since I
was a teenager in the 1980s in in which
there isn't some debate about him
integration which
and immigration which involves Muslims
as you know the proverbial other so much
so that we have data from national
representative survey conducted by the
Holocaust Center in in Norway in 2017
which suggested that some 34 percent I
think of Anna widgeon respondents in
that survey consent to the idea that
Muslims are in Norway and in Europe to
take over 34% yeah Wow
so that that's a very high percentage
and quite you know quite a frightening
percentage right because that obviously
also has you know consequences for how
people perceive their neighbors if they
happen to be of Muslim background we
know for a fact that Muslims experience
hate speech and hate crimes in Norway to
a greater extent than most other
minority but in in such a situation
there's always countervailing tendencies
and what I find in my work with youth in
you know multicultural multi-religious
neighbourhoods in in Oslo particularly
in Oslo East is of course what you would
expect
you know the situation you described a
you have neighbors that may be Muslim
and you have children getting to know
one other cross these boundaries right
so someone's opinion me contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on were on site
at the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia for our second
partnership with them we are now going
to be speaking with dr. Sindri bunk stud
hi Sandra
hi thanks for inviting me on the show
I'm very excited to talk to you there's
gonna be a lot of fun syndra's
backgrounds very interesting he's a
Norwegian social anthropologist he's
author of seven books associate
researcher at kifo Institute for church
religion and worldview research in Oslo
alright let's jump into things you know
that I like these big picture
conversations about are we really all
one yeah I mean obviously from an
anthropological point of view one of the
sort of fundamental ideas in
anthropology is that you know in spite
of particularities you know there's but
one human human race
and if we go even further back than that
and we look at whatever you want to call
it the Big Bang or creation or source or
all that is everything comes from one
does it feel that way I'm a normal
anthropologist so I'm not really
qualified to to go into you know the
those kind of of issues that that that's
obviously not my qualifications right
mm-hmm and then what about this most
upstream issue that society faces so
this part of the reason that we do the
show is because we get to kind of like
work with different fields on stretching
what conversations are normally only had
and like mmm like in a you know that
people may not have an assert in a given
setting try and like see if we can add
like philosophy or some sort of other
insights into the conversation hmm so
okay let's take a look at this most
upstream issue that society faces do you
think that it's our feelings of
separation from each other from nature
sort of these indigenous principles that
are being lacked in modernity well
there's obviously and I think in a lot
of societies on both sides of the
Atlantic and
and many other parts of the world
there's a sense of crisis at the moment
as the there's issues relating to you
know the lack of legitimacy for for the
political liberal political systems that
have
you know been quite successful since the
Second World War in terms of ensuring
you know welfare and stability and peace
and prosperity in in in Europe in
particular there's a profound sense that
you know of a crisis and that has also
obviously a lot of repercussions for how
people you know perceive that there were
immediate will and and their
surroundings right so one of the
articulations of this in in the European
context would be you know the rise of
anti-immigration Pollin politics which
we we've seen across the board and also
a sense in in which you know climate
change has become salient issue for a
lot of people this is such a strange
thing to have you know your answer to
the first question be that we are all
one and then that the this idea of
having some sort of a bias against other
people are treating them like that they
are not human or we dehumanize err that
we're disconnected from other people in
some way or their different skin color
different religion or what-have-you
different socioeconomic status and then
just all these ways of trying to
separate each other rather than see each
other as those brothers and sisters of
the one hmm I mean absolutely I mean
that there is a sort of a politics of
bordering which when once he is globally
and of course in the you in the European
context one of
of the foremost expressions of this new
politics of or bordering whereby you
know racialized minorities are excluded
is you know the extensive frontiers that
are sort of built around you in Europe
you have the use frontex project which
serve ales you know the the the sort of
border sounds of Europe with and in the
Mediterranean for example what's the EU
surveillance program called again on the
borders it's called Frontex right there
on tax yeah so what does it stand for
yeah no this is not my my sort of field
of research right but that this is an
entity that the EU and particulars
pumped billions of euros into okay and
the overall aim of that is to dissolve
curtail migration especially from from
African countries but also from Middle
Eastern countries in into Europe right
what what's the is this the you know is
this like similar thing around the world
like there's some so there's the sport
or conflict between Mexico and the
United States and immigration we have
the undocumented migration project that
Jason de Leon showcasing you know is
this a similar thing happening in the
Mediterranean with people trying to
cross into Europe is it you know people
why are people migrating is it what's
the main issue of towards economic
prosperity what is it the reason do you
know well I mean there are a lot of of
different issues obviously I mean a main
push factor in in recent years has been
this
renders conflict in in in Syria so war
yeah so for reasons relating to to war
and persecution but also I think you
know in in the foreseeable future we're
also looking at increasing flows of
economic migrants but also refugees
fleeing the consequences of global
climate change which by way of a paradox
right it's it's Western countries that
contribute the most if you accept China
to to global climate change but the
repercussions you know in terms of right
raising temperatures and increasing
desert the certificate technification as
experienced in in in in the global south
right okay so war moving towards
economic prosperity yet being completely
having causes that caused you to flee
from your home all these different types
of scenarios lead to this so then was it
then this the ethnographic fieldwork
that has been done by you has it's
ranged across different countries and
different religions different reasons
for migration all these different give
us some give some over some of the taste
of the social antic okay so i i've i'm
basically not a as called as an
anthropological scholar of migration my
research focus and my ethnographic
fieldwork the first fieldwork I did was
in among Muslims in Cape Town South
Africa in the early 2000s and then I've
done at no graphic fieldwork among
youth of Muslim minority background in
my native Norway and I've also written a
book about this the Weejun white
supremacist and right-wing extremist
mass murderer Anders Behring Breivik who
committed these appalling atrocities on
an island outside of Oslo the capital of
Norway
I do taya in to on July 22nd 2011 and
also faced a bomb on the government
headquarters in Oslo on the very same
day okay let's break into all three of
these theses
I'm so excited okay so the first one is
Muslims in South Africa yeah okay so
what was going on you said specifically
Cape Town in Cape Town yeah okay and so
what's what's happening because there's
obviously apartheid that happened
there's still some really what is it
African National Congress and the
Democratic Alliance mm-hmm there's some
very interesting politics still
happening and also healing that needs to
happen in many ways for what happened
since like the middle of the 1600s Intel
until now yeah but I mean those South a
four tide as a as a political system
might have disappeared of course the the
sort of the long shadows cast by apart
its afterlife is still very much salient
in in the everyday lives of South
Africans so my new graphic fieldwork
there was on on Muslims who in Cape Town
constitute probably 10% of the
population these are descendants of of
political prisoners but also slaves
brought from all across the Indian Ocean
basin under Dutch colonialism right so
from basically 1658 until 1808 I think
is this sort of cut out of of period but
most of these Muslims we're under the
apartheid racial classification i
categorized as as belonging to the so
called
collared sub group which basically meant
that you know they were part of a group
that the apartheid regime used as kind
of a buffer to maintain ideas about
white supremacy right so coloured South
Africans under apartheid we're in a lot
of senses told that they were you know
they were the better than the majority
black population but they could never be
whites right and so in the post
apartheid context it also has to be
mentioned in this context that
underpinning the apartheid system was a
particularly conservative version of you
know Christianity Calvinist Christianity
so you saw in politics and legislation
that Muslims were obviously also by
virtue of their having a different
religion second-class citizens under
important in the post-party context you
you've got this 1996 Constitution which
is a multiracial Constitution where
whereby all citizens recall regardless
of their faith
or ethnic background or in principle
equal citizens right but South Africa as
you know still remains one of the most
unequal societies on earth and and so in
in the context of of Muslims in in Cape
Town the transition to post upon its
society also in Taine's entailed a lot
of new freedoms you know there was a
process towards the gradual recognition
of Muslim marriages it became in a lot
of respects easier for Muslims to
express their religious identity in in
in public and so forth okay so this is
one of the big findings of the first one
is that post around 1996 it after all
that complexity it had become easier for
Muslims to express themselves freely in
public and marry have the marriages be
recognized and still about 10% of the
population or so in Capetown yes yeah as
to be said that in South Africa is it's
only 1.4 percent right so okay or
something like approximately right and
why do you pick you know there's gonna
be two more we'll get to but I'm just
curious like there's so many different
things to study as an anthropologist you
know how do you pick such a niche
Muslims in Cape Town yeah I mean I
basically came to Cape Town on South
Africa where the idea that I would do
ethnographic fieldwork on
on integration in formerly white
residential neighborhoods in in in
Capetown but on the report I'd of course
certain urban and suburban areas of of
Cape Town were declared as whites only
right so you couldn't legally live there
if if you weren't classified by the
system as as white in the post apartheid
context this residential segregation
still remains but now it has more to do
with issues of class and social economic
marginalization so people who are not
white generally can't afford to move
into historically white neighborhood
neighborhoods from which some of them
were quite as a substantial number where
were forcibly removed unreported when
these areas were declared white right so
I quickly realized that this was not it
was not viable for me to do research on
that and I discovered that you know
there hadn't been for example a
doctorate on Muslims in Cape Town since
the late 1970s and I was also introduced
to okay see there's there's this feeling
of catching up on an itch that hadn't
had good research done in it for 30 ya
know that was definitely a sort of
lacunae in in in ethnographic fieldwork
on on Muslims in in Cape Town yes
so that seemed like a viable option and
also I I gradually
gradually I was introduced to and became
friends with with Muslim families in a
in a Township community south of Cape
Town so that was really the the start of
my career as an anthropologist which I'm
still profoundly grateful for because
now with without that experience and and
when you're a young and apologist that
is you know profoundly important to sort
of realize that you can you can actually
do this you know you know I get along
with people who in in some respects are
quite different from you but in other
respects you know share the kind of
qualities and what the makeup that makes
us all human right yeah this is a very
important point I like this so then
actually this is a big part of doing
fieldwork is that in many ways their hat
there is something that happens that
usually there has to be some sort of a
behavior change of sorts you have to
repattern
maybe some of the processes that you
know you weren't used to like the
enquiring into is this like asking
questions to Muslim families in Cape
Town and like learning about their
traditions and where things were a
decade ago where they are now and taking
it like that hmm yeah absolutely yeah so
this is very interesting you when you do
fieldwork like this it really requires a
you know it requires openness it
requires a shift towards knowing how to
you know be polite and ask good
questions and be respectful of the
culture that's that's um maybe slightly
different like you were describing okay
so the second one was you said young
Muslims in your home country in Norway
yep okay so now what are what's going on
with that okay so Norway is is quite a
small country right the population
is now estimated at 5.3 million people
in Norway and in the Norwegian context
that's about the size of Vancouver I
think our Bureau unlike in the South
African context where there's been a
Muslim present continuous Muslim
president for 300 years right
Muslim migration to Norway is quite a
recent phenomenon right so when did it
start well we have historical records
suggesting that the first Muslim dyi or
missionary arrived in Norway in the
1920s he never settled the first settled
Muslim in in Norway was enough medivh
proselytizer athma DZ's yeah there you
know muslims from a muslim sect from the
india in indo-pakistani subcontinent
right and quite engaged in proselytizing
or missionary activities known as Dawa
in in various parts of the world so
there was a small community of Othmani
Muslims in Oslo and sometimes
missionaries come and proselytize
sometimes and sometimes they come to and
settle without yeah proselytizing this
is but there was a nut made' of
Pakistani bar crown who settled in Oslo
West in the 1950s and who around them
there emerged a small congregation
consisting of rock Mahdi's and some
region converts right but the main wave
of Muslim migration in always starts in
the 19 late nineteen sixties with Muslim
labour male predominantly male labor
migration from various countries but
predominantly
[Music]
Pakistan Turkey Morocco and so 19 by
1975 this had generated this sort of
moral panic in in the Norwegian
political system so there was a cross
political consensus and majority support
in in Parliament for what was known as
an immigration stop and the aim of that
immigration stop was to curb immigration
from so-called third world countries but
by that time you know there were already
hundreds of predominantly male labor
migrants from Muslim countries who had
rights to family reunification which
meant that you know many of them brought
their families over from their home
countries through the 1970s and 80s and
the 1990s there were quite a number of
asylum client claimants people who
sought refuge in in Norway from various
majority Muslim countries so for example
refugees from Iran there were refugees
coming from the wars in the Balkans
Somali Somalia
and after 2000 also Iraq in recent years
refugees from the Syrian civil war hmm
whoa okay so there are there's this
interesting feeling where you kind of
have like a homogeneous tribe of let's
say five million people but a
homogeneous tribe you can even scale it
down to just the Dunbar 150 if you want
for the example but then they soak a so
called other of
and skin color or religion or some kind
of status or whatever comes and miss
seeking to maybe become integrated with
the tribe or to settle there proselytize
there's so many different options but
then this idea of maybe like a fear can
kick in where you do something like want
an immigration stop and not allow any of
that to happen
sometimes you try and open up the door
and try and make sure that people are
you know mentally healthy and that they
will not cause harm in that tribe where
they are trying to enter there are so
many different approaches to this
process but also this is very important
to understand that the whole planet is
our collective home and that these
borders when you're orbiting in the
International Space Station are looking
for Mars etc do not exist and so there
is also that to keep in mind while also
wanting to be a secure place of security
into a place of prosperity and of
enabling people to enter when they have
had war or their conflict or seeking
economic prosperity or all these
different types of things this is a very
complicated mixing of all these
different variables that have to be
analyzed in situations like this
absolutely it has to be said that the
Muslim population men of nowhere now
stands at an estimated four point two
percent of the population so it's a
that's quite a jump from several hundred
yeah no no sure yeah and I mean there's
been by all means significant
demographic change in Norway since the
late 1960s right so if we look at the
official statistics I
it's estimated that seventeen point four
percent of the Rieger population I have
an immigrant background or is descended
from from him immigrants in in the
capital of Oslo that percentage raises
to some thirty six point eight percent I
mean obviously you know
that's not always a smooth process but
IIIi think if you look at indicators
such as labor market positive
participation and levels of education
this is certainly a slow process but no
way you know it is a case in point if
you want to make the case that you know
fears about Muslim immigration often
become completely overblown right if you
look at you know media and political
discourses there is not a single day and
there hasn't been since I was a teenager
in the 1980s in in which there isn't
some debate about him integration which
and immigration which involves Muslims
as you know the proverbial other and and
part of the challenging and Weejun
context is not only that this has
happened relatively fast it's also as
the late in which and social
anthropologist Mariana gula star
remarked in in one of our books it's
it's also related to the fact that
Norwegians tended to think of themselves
as being quite a homogeneous population
right which if you look at this
historically they're certainly truths in
in that perception but with quite strong
qualifications because no way has this
indigenous Sami population which has
been the present in over four centuries
there you talk well you know in in
northern Norway there were the
indigenous population what what is the
indigenous part
Norway called the the Sammy's zombies
and you had you know Jews and Rome and
Roma speaking people's in in in Norway
so it it was not the case that Norwegian
society was always homogeneous right yes
yes
wow this is such an interesting
combinatoric that is flowering on the
planet because when you look at what you
know used to be what you were you know
describing if at the very beginning like
South Africa and like the year 1600 and
then what happened and where it is now
the United States and 1600 and then what
happened and where it is now I mean look
at what city were in right now Vancouver
yeah you know the indigenous here then
very white and and then very now there's
lots of Chinese people lots of Indian
people lots of Persian people lots of
now you know boom now there's a like now
this becomes its own melting pot of
cultures in a sense as well but the
percentages are actually super
interesting that you were listening
because no nor um a country like the
United States that has 330 million
people and then like I don't even know
probably only half of them now are white
I don't know what the number is China
which has a 1.4 billion people but
probably won't point 3 billion over them
are Chinese you know so this is very
interesting or way which has 5 million
5.3 million but then now maybe a couple
hundred thousand are actually not
Norwegian and that's also very
interesting how these things flower as
its own unique like combinatoric and
what you know what economic and societal
pressures funnel people into countries
and a war pressures etc colonization
pressures all different types of things
happening and it's also interesting
thinking about like after even a couple
of generations of migrating into a land
like let's say Norway
that then let's say that if I'm Muslim
my my children whether I'm you know from
maybe my a I'm from Somalia I that or
Syria that whatever it may be that my
children play with your children and the
other children that are Norwegian
children and then they become friends
and which is great and but maybe even
some of them decide to get married and
have children and then that's that
statistic that you were talking about
where it's I think over 30 percent of
backgrounds in noir and also
specifically yeah our yeah yeah our
mother places now so I mean no ways
obviously in a sort of transitional
phase but it you know we we have to also
recall that you know if if we look at
this in in in in broad historical sweeps
right the the the sort of natural human
condition as has been movement of people
and has been mixing right Valentin
mixing
yeah yeah no I mean look at the the work
of this famous geneticist David right
right so there you know we swirl our
genes with no but sort of demonstrates
that there's been much more mixing and
geographical movement across the
centuries than what we we tend to an are
egg are capable of imagining right so in
in the Norwegian context and and we have
this populist right-wing party in
government which has introduced you know
more restrictions on immigration than
any Norwegian government since world war
war two and it's a specific targeting of
of Muslims in that policy in that
you know it's though you can't do that
I'm not in international law it's quite
obvious that it's the particular target
is Muslim immigration to Norway but in
in such a situation there's always
countervailing tendencies and what I
find in my work with youth in you know
multicultural multi-religious
neighborhoods in Oslo particularly in
Oslo East is of course what you would
expect
you know the situation you describe you
have neighbors that may be Muslim and
you have children getting to know one of
across these boundaries right so where I
live in a suburban community outside of
Oslo I have a neighbor who you still use
bobsleds up there yeah who's of Muslim
background right and I mean he's highly
educated and his children play with all
the other children in the neighborhood
right yes and I think you know then this
movement in mixing yeah and so the to
the extent that I you know see is he
hope it is often in in the younger
generation that they'd learn too and I'm
not saying that it's always an
inevitable on problematic but there is a
sense of what my friend Paul Gilroy
refers to as conviviality right corner
VV ality yeah which is a way of
referring to this everyday and
and white you know regular interaction
yes conviviality like with living with
yeah life with and by having life with
on the playgrounds from early days of
life it becomes normal to see a mixing
and movement of people that are
so-called different whereas older people
that I may have never seen that yeah
yeah that's so interesting we were
talking about that in some of the
previous interviews during the annual
meeting where it's almost as though this
this young consciousness of like
stewardship of the planet and desire for
interconnectedness with each other and
nature and our ecosystems is slowly
coming and overthrowing the archaic
systems of not giving us about the
nature and about the ecosystems and and
it's it's very interesting that that a
young consciousness is moving and also
if we look at this sort of mobilization
against climate change environmental
mobilization of environmental issues in
Norway its is often as in you know many
other countries driven by youth yeah
we're building the next world young
people we believe in you to build the
next world and solve the greatest
challenges that our society faces and
become the most enlightened that is the
world's passed along to okay last one
okay so on there's breathing yeah okay
what is your argument is that Brevik
beliefs were not simply the result of a
deranged mind but rather they are the
result of the political mainstreaming of
pernicious racist in Islamophobic
discourses hmm give us the background on
what this is and how one can even
calculate such multivariable 'ti of
impact on
one's choices okay right so I mean
there's a risk of sort of reducing the
actions of Brevig to a question of
social psychology right so we we we know
that this was a character with who had a
trouble family background right
[Music]
fatherhood basically left the family
when he was still a child that's a big
traumatic factor yeah absolutely and he
he also had a mother who wasn't from the
look of it very functional and so the
psychiatric emulation in in the context
of of the court case found for example
that he had you know a severe lack of
empathy and narcissistic impulses right
yes but my book on on the brave ik
affair isn't attempt to take you know
his ideological motivations seriously
without necessarily reducing his actions
to a sort of causal relationship where
exposure to a right-wing extremist the
ideology and Islamophobia leads to those
kinds of of actions because you know
first of all there are there's a lot of
of this hatred against Muslims and other
minorities not the least online and also
in in in in Norway and in vice-versa
happening as well yeah so
I mean it's not new and most people in
in in most countries would have a sort
of inner threshold where exposure to
that kind of rhetoric of vicious hatred
wouldn't lead to to violence and
terroristic actions right so that has to
be said but you know to my mind
Breivik was also profoundly inspired by
what is known as the counter jihadist
genre in which there's a lot of
dehumanization of of Muslims there's an
undercurrent of this conspiratorial
Arabia idea whereby the basic idea here
is that you know European governments
and the EU in particular are sort of
secretly involved in a conspiracy with
with Muslims to take over Europe in in
the name of Islam and to establish an
Islamic state or a Caliphate it's called
your eurabia eat the Arabia and and that
you know if you look at this in in the
context of conspiracy theories it's
something akin to the odd symmetric
forgery the the protocols of the Elders
of Zion only with Muslims cost as the
villains in in in the play if you like
there's a lot of Saudi Arabian money
going to different places in the world
though and that's very interesting to
study and follow the money trail yeah I
know certainly yes
but I mean if you look at the the
Norwegian context this way of thinking
about a relatively small and too many
extension and purposes quite
marginalized minority
has become surprisingly mainstream and
widespread so much so that we have data
from national representative survey
conducted by the Holocaust Centre in in
Norway in 2017 which suggested that some
34% I think of an Allegiant respondents
in that survey consent to the idea that
Muslims are in Norway and in Europe to
take over 34% yeah Wow so that that's a
very high percentage and quite you know
quite a frightening percentage right
because that obviously also has you know
consequences for how people perceive
their neighbors if they happen to be of
Muslim background we know for a fact
that Muslims experience hate speech and
hate crimes in Norway to a greater
extent and then most other minority Wow
damn and and so brave ik was also a
product of the mainstreaming of these
ideas what what year were brave exit rah
cities and what were the numbers will
work his atrocities that he caused okay
right so the this happened on and these
were you know the worst terrorist
attacks in in modern Norwegian history
and they occurred on July 22nd 2011 and
the number of casual casualties I think
was 77
so and most of his victims were
teenagers attending a youth camp for the
then governing Social Democratic Labour
Party's youth organization at ETA which
is more Island 60 kilometers from from
Oslo there were also some casualties
relating from the bomb that was that
created significant damage in government
headquarters in in central Oslo prior to
the massacres at detail
so at ujr there's now quite a moving
memorial to the victims of of Breivik's
terrorist attacks because these we're
you know innocent teenagers killed in in
cold blood and completely defenseless
right soon and so this is very difficult
trying to understand what were you know
you started a soft with the traumatic up
even at the most young age of a father
leaving mother maybe not raising the
child that well and then having all
these other yeah but the
counter-argument here is is always and
is important to emphasize that you know
if even in prosperous country with an
advanced welfare state such as as no way
quite a number of children experience
trauma during their youth right
dysfunctional parents what not it very
rarely leads to those kind of
consequences right so yeah there's so
many variables so we've heard about
tumors pressing against people's
amygdala we've heard about buying guns
on black markets or there's no
background checks no ID sex we've heard
about conspiracy theories and what that
leads to propaganda and phobia of others
there's all different types of variables
that go into these types of analyses and
Wow
I'm curious your thoughts on this
because you know given the context of us
moving into a eight billion person
globalized world where artificial
intelligence and robotics is permeating
into every single industry we have this
kind of talked about this a little bit
at the beginning but we have this in a
sense we're kind of in many ways also
those kind of different at least I
haven't been yet but I've here in a see
when I see Google Maps and all this type
of stuff just this much more five
million people in a in a massive country
and like a little bit more focus on not
choking out the natural environment in a
sense whereas here it's just just
stacking people on top of each other
choking on national environment less
Park's less tree etc so like in many
ways it's like looking at indigenous
principles of interconnectedness
immediate return hunter-gatherers all
this type of stuff sacredness of the
land and each other and trying to embed
those into metropolis as we move forward
into that a crazy
AIH how do you feel about that big
mixing pot with the amount of people
globalization artificial intelligence
trying to bring principles of
indigeneity and move them into mountain
modernity how do you feel about all that
that that's admittedly a challenging
question given that a you know that this
is not you know part of my
anthropological competencies but IIIi I
do think that in
in sort of wider context also in the
context of debates on climate change and
and mentalists there's this sense that
that Norway's exceptional and stands
apart but we do have this you know state
control petroleum company known as
Ecuador which is listed among the 50
worst polluters in in the world right
and and so even in Norway which is an
advanced economy right we have I do
think there's more Tesla's per capita in
in in in Norway than in most other
countries right that's what per capita
yeah so I I do think you know that there
are some serious challenges as far as
Norway is concerned as well and that
we're not you know as much ahead of the
game as it or as far as the struggle
against climate change is concerned as
as many people who in other parts of the
world looking at Norway from the outside
would would like to think right and
there are also you know serious issues
relating to you know conflicts of land
rights for the indigenous Sami
population in in in in Norway which
historically has also been victims of of
what we refer to as processes of
racialization where they were you know
historically seen as not Norwegian in
fact experienced you know centuries of
forced assimilation and discriminatory
language policies so much so that that
Sami children were not permitted
to speak their own language in in wigeon
schools in their home areas until the
late 1960s right and there's obviously
you know in in the current context
there's there's a lot of things to learn
I think from individuals populations
especially in regard to and I'm saying
this not in order to romanticize this
because that often happens but but but
there certainly things to learn about
you know interaction with with the
natural environment which you know
urbanized Norwegians may not be as
attuned to as they should be right what
do you think is next for your interest
in social anthropology and where you
want to study well I mean you know that
it also depends on funding streams but I
have this chance now to go back to to
South Africa NACA next year for a sort
of revisit we have obtained funding for
a project on what what we've global
flows of Islamaphobia so I'm part of the
research team and and Maya day is to
next year hopefully go back to to South
Africa for a revisit the global flows of
Islamophobia yeah so the the underlying
idea here is that one often all too
often one analyzes this in the specific
nation-state context right what is what
is then often missed in research on that
phenomenon is the ways in which you know
social media flows for example means
that particular ideas about Islam and
Muslims are become transnational right
you can find them in in in quite
different parts of the world right so
you can find some of the same ideas
among Hindu nationalists in India
Hindutva people and among Buddhists in
in Myanmar some of the same ideas about
Islam and Muslims which are all
stereotypes right but there is a flow in
all directions of these particular ideas
and and and that has to be studied
empirically and this is part of the key
for well I'm based at Kiefer which is an
independent Research Institute right so
we mainly do Commission research other
kinds of research but this is
one of the the key projects that we have
obtained funding for for coming years
yeah and what are the other macro things
that kifo is looking at well as we're
reasonably small right so we mostly do
Commission research in in the field of
[Music]
you know Christianity and various like
life stance communities in in Norway
there are short term projects designed
to say something about you know specific
topics relating to christianity other
life stances other religions in in
Norway syndra have another question what
do you think is most beautiful well
right now most beautiful I can think of
is Vancouver right I had this wonderful
bike ride through Stanley Park some
three hours yesterday which was you know
given weather here right now quite
extraordinary and and it's kind of you
know that comes from my upbringing also
in Norway where the outdoors has been
extremely important for me so that was
absolutely wonderful
hmm and most beautiful yeah this place
is so magical my goodness just a
ridiculously big recommendation to
people to check out Vancouver British
Columbia I mean wow
there's just there's really just nothing
that just pops like what you look at
when you look at like North Vancouver
across the water and just it just feels
like the mountains and trees are just
talking to you and the water is just
talking to you
this is sunlights just so gorgeously
shining on edges yeah they're so
beautiful
syndra thank you for joining us on the
program
yeah this has been an honor thank you
and thank you for having me
you're super welcome I'm feel I feel
like just a bunch of new ways of seeing
things that's how I feel right now and
thank you for sharing all of those with
us everyone thank you for tuning in and
checking out the program we greatly
appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on all the things that
drew is teaching us check out his links
in the bio below and support him let us
know on all these complex topics that he
was sharing what you think check out the
links in the bio below to the American
Anthropological Association go and
support them and help them grow and
flourish as well you can find our links
in the bio below as well at the
simulation so you can continue doing
cool things like coming on site to the
American Anthropological Association
Annual Meeting and doing cool
partnerships with people like them
support us PayPal patreon cryptocurrency
all those links are in the bio below and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon okay yeah
thank you
[Music]